I'm just feeling a little insecure I
feel like my hips have just spread like
waiter no return
yeah like my favorite jeans they're
never gonna fit me again I know curves
are hard it's just figuring it out Kylie
Jenner admits to Kim Kardashian she's
self-conscious about her body after
giving birth to daughter stormy like
nothing in my closet fits me but you're
looking like really skinny thank you I'm
gonna rip that I just feel like never
gonna fit me like I know I know I'm not
gonna fit until like a 25 Jane ever
again on Keeping Up with the Kardashians
Kim has a heart-to-heart with Kylie
about adjusting to her post pregnancy
figure as the lip cake Creator cleans
out her closet like some people like
colic just body shamers trust me I get
it but the pressure to snap back like it
took me a good six to eight months once
I got there I was like okay I'm never
leaving
[Applause]
I want to wear things that make me feel
good about myself and still feel sexy
the mom of three has dealt with her fair
share of body shaming over the years you
take pictures and if they're not like
perfect people just like body shaming
you and criticize you and offer words of
wisdom to her little sis about how to
regain your confidence after baby I will
tell you this just wear two pairs of
shapewear and get out of the house it's
like you just have never cared for those
things like I never now I get it
yeah I literally would wear sometimes
I'm not joking you three pairs of
shapewear just to get out of the house
and I know it's like really early and
stormy so little but like you just have
to roll with it you know you just have
to like be confident get some things
that make you feel good about yourself
and find your balance no I agree words
otherwise I always say you do inspire me
a lot if Kim can do it I could do it
[Music]
[Applause]